the Antics inside the Johnny Depp vs
Amber Heard trial are almost as wild as
the Antics outside of it welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight kev's
off tonight Amber's cross-examination
came to a dramatic close with all eyes
zeroing in on the woman fighting for
Johnny in court
this is a real monster in this
relationship Miss heard that's the knife
you gave to the man who was hitting you
right mister Camille the people want to
know are you dating Johnny Depp
it's all over the internet can you set
the record straight
Johnny's attorney Camille Vasquez didn't
comment but a source close to the trial
tells E.T that the romance rumors are
100 unequivocally untrue Camille who
embraced Johnny after she grilled Amber
has become an overnight star of the
trial for another reason her tough
cross-examination so you never changed
your own behavior to support Mr death
and his sobriety did you as of today
you have not paid 3.5 million dollars of
your own money to the ACLU yes or no
I have not yet today we're learning more
about Camille the 38 year old and
associate with an Orange County Law Firm
focusing on defamation suits she went to
school in La USC undergrad and law
school at Southwestern she's reportedly
dating a Brit who works in real estate
as for Amber's image well it's not great
Lance Bass posted this Tick Tock video
reenacting the actress's testimony I was
just sitting here on this on on this
carpet looking at the dirty carpet
wondering how I wound up on this carpet
and why I was never why I never noticed
that the carpet was so filthy before
it's a friend very sad to me though that
try I don't know how anybody wins in
that case I really don't Amber's younger
sister Whitney took the stand today at
some point she wasn't even allowed to
have passwords on her phone both she and
Amber were matching split broken heart
necklaces what if any changes Did You
observe in Amber it was like watching a
slow motion gunshot she suddenly stopped
sleeping as much she maybe weighed a
hundred pounds soaking wet she was
emaciated she wasn't sleeping
occasionally I'd see a bruising
cut lips split lips weird marks it was
just weird but there were injuries to
her
listen I'm like everybody else I cannot
get enough of this trial if you want to
follow it or watch it it is streaming on
our YouTube channel you can find it
there
[Music]